hidey ho rejectos welcome to the real
rejects episodes excellent reaction of
the witcher season two guys if you could
toss a coin at that like button that'd
be very much appreciated subscribe to
get accepted to the reject nation but
also to get notified when our reaction
to the next witcher episode is up as
always you've heard me say this before
full length watch as long as we sync up
with the time coder over at our patreon
page major thanks to all that becomes
superjects because we cover so many
shows over there as well lastly them
handsome boys at prepper thank you sexy
sobs for helping us edit down these
highlights let's get to it
how much further is it
where are we even going are we there yet
you want to kill yourself trying to
become a mutant so if you survive you
can kill yourself trying to get revenge
ironic
all you care about is damn duty which is
protecting your ass
girl get back here
don't hurt roach i swear to god
[Music]
run
someone
is back
what did he take did he get the vial
oh
[ __ ] oh you better kill that chernobog
oh man
[ __ ] that
do a barrel roll
oh
his feet too damn
yeah they died drudge dirty like that
man i know
i better be a full in memoriam for roach
at our chooser they taught us the art of
politics art of persuasion quick time to
bend others so they think that they're
in control the art of the deal
that's exactly what i was thinking
huge the white flame rules me off guard
yes
but my people the face they see that
feeds them every day that welcomes them
in from the cold is yours you're the
real leader
accept it accept it peacocks
it's time to return to the real reason
that we took sintra in the first place
the girl was last seen in sodom and told
oh perfect time
dude yeah what a convenient ease drop in
time
i haven't dropped no easter honest yeah
came for me the pool
i don't think it wanted to hurt me
i didn't want to hurt you
he doesn't know about her vision right i
don't think so later there were also
some men from cintra who found me who
are going to take me to the night to
collect her award
i killed them geralt how many were there
four you've got some catching up tonight
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's sent me here when i was about
your age yes
i too was once a child you can see some
of that in the nightmare of the world of
the wolf
solid foreign
one of our best student and lover find
what is missing in the girl then maybe
you stand a chance of helping her she's
missing
acceptance missing a home
she's what's most important now
that baby's gonna be the villain of
season three
fire magic is off limits for us
whoever he is he's not working for the
brotherhood that dude's all about fire
i didn't think vesimer is what he was
after well at least he left empty-handed
oh he grabbed something
you knew it
this wasn't part of our arrangement what
do you want to meet your employer
better to be the right hand of the devil
than in his path
you expect to get out of that temple
with the rest of your face intact you'll
need a crew
montage
i need information oh
information
that cat is every cat i've ever seen in
a bookstore
how do you know who i am we know lots of
things
we
but this is faith
i'm fan
the cat says miranda what the [ __ ]
you're who to ask uh sensitive questions
sensitive questions are our favorite
they come very expensive very expensive
i need to know what a witcher
a monolith and a mysterious girl have to
do with nilfgaard
it's a setup to my favorite joke these
are nilf guardian mouse
do you work for them
does it matter only that it makes you
more
interesting
[Laughter]
the girl is cyrilla of sintra and how do
you know that
like i told you
we know lots of things what a great way
to explain away anything
it's your bocum
i'm not sure well well that's a tool
for mages i'd want to brag but
my tool is
bigger uh-huh and much more powerful oh
yes
nice whip it out
see the outlet
sorry
you big old tool i'm spreading my tire
yeah dick would do that coil that thing
back up i'm gonna pop off a piece of my
dick
hello
say yen
[Music]
can i help you no no i was just admiring
the architecture oh it's beautiful isn't
it
i've got something better than
architecture this is my knowledge
i'll be with you in a minute siri
he
[Music]
don't just hop straight to sex guys
talk about a couple things first
carol do you know what to do with this
sorry siri sorry
i'm different
dear friend
what the hell should we call it i mean
especially after the way you guys left
off
you're jennifer and you must be his
child surprise oh [ __ ] she's put
together
[Music]
this week on witcher
things get complicated how will they
wriggle out of this one
having so much fun with this
what the hell is your problem dude
geralt says you're the most powerful
mage you've ever known
well that's nice of him i i didn't say
most past you know what a lot of mages
out there
i
dreamed about you once before i even
knew you existed
perhaps we were meant to find each other
i can go to bed now
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn
she's like full squatting yeah
just like that
oh no
the show hates babies
oh come on friendzilla
whisper some life into her
[Music]
you're the luckiest baby in this entire
realm
how was that magic necromancer
dude's gonna come and i challenged the
baby to a sword
then he must have loved you
very much
hatred is an endless
circle of fear and desperation amen you
may have the ability to break
the cycle of hatred
once and for all
only a hundred more candles to go in
that direction
is every night
that's beautiful
yes
a little love
thanks for translating that
in english please fantasize about you
quite a bit
that golem was ripping my insides out
now that your head was torn off by one
how romantic
i ran into yes yeah this fire [ __ ] it
was after him a mage i don't know who he
was he's looking for siri
why what is she tame
yen
your heart has been beating fast this
whole
time i have some wounds that refuse to
heal
you still want to have a child
no it's she forgot all about that
way to bring it up that's how much
different for the both of us
yeah
i need to find siri
funny you should mention that
we could want cirilla to have a
legitimate claim to cedro
no you know it's probably pure
coincidence that emir wants the princess
with the secret power to shatter
monoliths for her claim to a throne that
he already took by force
but this is present
which is more like dress
right right right of course duh the
elves didn't build a weapon they built a
warrior oh [ __ ]
lara doran
that's their mission
to hear the emperors
to find her
she is the reason they came to central
no don't talk to the owl i know because
i helped siri escape
and then i lost them myself
don't let the black elves get dreads i
guess so
racist
good thing you got a big old ball and
chain yeah i think's gonna become a
weapon
what happened
what happened oh no
knowledge boy
oh
oh god
hello siri
it's so nice to finally put a face to a
name oh you dick
oh
yeah let's do it
siri
nice scar [ __ ] head fire [ __ ]
like siri
i'll find you afterwards
oh no she's in love with siri oh jen's
got a way out now
[Music]
whoa
[ __ ] damn
wow
[Applause]
damn
whoa
holy balls
[Music]
oh my god
that was awesome
and it isn't mine
which means you need to get us out of
here create a portal siri do it lesson
number one
see the outcome
make it happen
wow
siri
yen
stop
i wish i could
oh
no
oh he was just so heartbroken when he
saw it let me mutagen
it's gone and that's somewhere i need to
go
that should make it all better damn
investment are just having a [ __ ] season
tris
what are you doing here i wasn't smoking
pot
i know for a fact
a drop of her blood could change the
world in the wrong hands she will
destroy it
oh
no now
well [ __ ]
no pressure siri
normally the first thing i don't
want to talk about is the action scenes
and stuff
but
why is that funny
it's not why is it funny why are you
laughing at this you know what there's a
sincere thought
[Laughter]
yeah but that was a comedy laugh oh it
was it was a punchline in and of itself
i don't know why i laughed at that but
uh i because it's a curious thing i'm
like oh yeah you really do we don't
usually start off talking about the
action anyway what were you gonna say
uh
exactly that i specifically teed that up
so you would laugh at something again
that's not funny so i could call you out
on laughing at something that's that's
that was the original
review i had a plan from the very
beginning i can anticipate it from a
mile away yeah yeah this guy's gonna say
something it's not at all funny he's
gonna laugh some things are you know
cute and clever in a broad sense and
then overall i know dude i totally get
it man i i'm sure you do
i was about i was ready to just see i i
knew that was happening anyway uh the
action in this episode
was just uh that was the first thing
that in this season that hearken back to
the first episode of this whole series
like that that opening fight i think is
a really big
moment in the witcher where
even though people were weren't
immediately hooked a lot of people
weren't because it's kind of a
complicated show to get on board for and
follow at first yeah
that episode's action scene was like
damn that was cool then that was that
was brutal and then here what i loved
about it was hey buddy yeah i just
wanted to starting to talk you want to
go in the scratcher that makes sense
go for it buddy make a bunch of noise go
start destroying stuff
but that first episode um was is this
different kind of fight scene you know
he has a sword he's messing up just
civilians who don't stand up like a
chance basically and here they introduce
the the marx brothers really that's
right
the michelin
michelin brothers yeah they they
introduce
uh them which doesn't seem like i don't
know maybe to you guys there's an
additional lore that you know about them
that we don't really comprehend
but um what was cool about that was
there was no sword involved that he just
had to use his fists and then he kind of
used his environment and the way they
blended whatever that like force push
thing is that he yeah yeah that neo move
yeah and like the way they utilized that
that implemented it into the
choreography with some hyper stylized
camera work
was really neat i thought that was like
the
that was the best action we've gotten of
the whole it's just so like
it's a it comes from a place of
protection
and it's
primal and visceral and
it's not like
overblown even though there's some crazy
stylized stuff but it's really gory and
violent it was just cool it was a cool
fight to behold man
and uh like that one shot especially
where he just
pulls out the sword lands on it i'm like
that's freaking clever choreography
that's great choreography yeah
absolutely and that's a fight where
where geralt has to use more of that
sort of spatial resourcefulness because
that original first episode fight yeah
he's laying dudes out with a sword
whereas here yeah it's like all these
guys have the drop on him they have
their weapons and he has to rely on the
environment so not only yeah you get
these stylistic influx but you also have
to watch geralt kind of
it's a different kind of thing while
also giving you the same level of thrill
it's like he's gotta work a little
harder for it even though you know he's
probably done this yeah for sure
for sure um
and uh i i think that what's his name
what what's what's what's dude here okay
here okay here yeah
um
the guy
doesn't seem to have
progressed at all as a person
since he got back he got back he's like
switch back on thank god that's over
hard man
zero humbling experience even though
boarding the ship with the l secret
refuge has been landing me here
no no no no
no
sympathy the hell happened with this guy
i thought there'd be like some type of
at least a hint of change or complexity
towards being which way he's getting
kind of pulled
but right away he's like white flame
don't trust these guys frangillo what's
wrong with you
i'm back
right away yeah
and uh cast in doubt i don't know how i
feel about that of course i'll wait for
the season to progress but that kind of
threw me for a loop a little bit yeah
yeah i keep forgetting the fire is um
completely outlawed yeah since they can
do so much they do so much magic and i
keep forgetting that fire is like oh
yeah that's the one
they can't do especially because that's
like the only thing that guy does yeah
exactly is the extra bad because that's
all he wants to do but i kept kind of
viewing it as a um
it's not really a strength because it
just seems like that's all he can do
well then i forget that
with the mages that's um that's a big
thing that's
not permitted well and it's also too
like they established that and i assume
all the magic in some way shape or form
has they talked about this like
equivalent exchange law but it seems
like with fire it's more intense of like
you've got to give up some of your life
force so you got to get you know energy
from somewhere to trade for this fire
and so it seems like to have that be
your whole thing would probably be
pretty
difficult although that's also what
makes rance such a badass i guess
kind of
how did he know to go to
to uh yeah okay morn how do you know to
go there
um
that's a good question
i can't fully remember maybe it's just
because he knows geralt's a witcher or
something like that he was like it's the
winter maybe i'll head there first or
something i can't remember no actually
actually that's a really logical thing
to jump to yeah i don't think there was
any like explicit like i don't know he's
probably here when he's talking like how
do you know how do you know the vile
that yeah i mean that's a good question
it seems like he just appeared it was
like action and then yeah it's like
i guess i'll just take this so you can
get this very important thing or maybe
he was spying there for a while yeah
well yeah they they mentioned that like
spy mission but in the action of the
episode it just felt like that spy
mission was literally him portaling into
where vesimir was for ten seconds and
again blast it back out again but yeah
maybe
maybe he's got ears
this this temp i i wonder
sometimes like with this show in
particular sometimes with its like
introduction of lore and then kind of
feeling like we're moving on a little
fast yeah it can be a little bit jarring
because
like you they have this whole thing with
syrian and him traveling to the temple
and then
you know it's like you think you're
getting here to really learn some [ __ ]
like you're going to learn some stuff
and it's going to be an expansion
and an extension and a big learning
lesson for
the siri
but it just kind of seemed like the the
station where jennifer then would meet
and then this then they're gone from
there now yeah and i don't know there's
always two more episodes left and it's
always a place you can go revisit and
have reoccurring characters and whatnot
uh
but i felt like there was like i i at
the end of the episode i i feel like
there's a lack of substance that
occurred from being there other than
some like sage words of pondering wisdom
to perhaps contemplate of
you can do it siri yeah yeah because i i
liked that you know when we show up at
karamorin in certain places you spend
time better yeah and it sets you up to
expect those kind of things and here i
think i may be
i don't know yet we'll see i i maybe got
a little more out of this than like the
brachilon forest
interludes but this did feel like the
kind of thing where it's like okay
here's where we'll spend the next
chapter oh no i guess we won't yeah this
is just a weigh station where we'll do a
couple things and then we'll move on and
get sort of an interesting flesher out
of the world like i i really like that
character i can't remember her name now
but you know like the woman who presides
over the whole place and her
interactions with siri and i was like oh
this could be like i would be excited to
see them interact more and see some more
of her training through this character's
eyes sure um and yeah i mean not to say
that we could never come back or see
that character again but it does yeah as
the episode ends up
feel very
brief and like it yeah is a stepping
stone it's like there's all this
potential of like learn how to use this
orb thing
and uh you know it kind of just seemed
like plot device
stuff to me and nothing that was real
like let's get
let's get these characters here they
were the orbs that way jennifer can take
him this way
yeah this was an episode that felt like
okay we're in a location and even like
with the the brothers who showed up
later i'm like there are a lot of things
in this episode where i bet the books
have like a lot more stuff dedicated to
this and i can just imagine and maybe
i'm wrong but i can just imagine you
know readers being like oh yeah in the
books we spend a lot more time here it's
a lot more consequential
but uh but sometimes i feel like as cool
as the action is that it sometimes
sacrifices some exploration for thrills
yeah which the thrills i enjoy that's
that's the thing is like i i really
enjoy the the the exciting [ __ ] i always
hear yeah it's just sometimes i look
back and i go but i kind of feel like we
uh
maybe in season one we might have kind
of seen what's going on here a little
bit more yeah had a little bit more to
do to develop the character yeah it
feels like we would have we would have
rested and spit like there's something
about the way that we arrive in uh yeah
in that uh mellitelli
where like it i just remember that i did
i didn't read the screen right now at
all i didn't see the episode synopsis
and quickly zero in on the right word
but uh yeah even just the like the whole
presentation of it feels
like the even just the style like
doesn't come to
what cues you into like a rest or into
like yeah we're gonna dive in here i
thought on the opposite side of the
episode
that was probably the most
tangible to me with the simon callow
character and and lenny kravitz that's
what they do with um this dread yeah
which is like wait wait
no lenny kravitz
but uh like that was the thing where i
was like oh this is cool and i'm like
enjoying these characters who kind of
remind me of uh of billy crystal and and
his and uh
princess bride yeah
you know yeah
they reminded me of them and just you
know even though it is like a
fact-finding mission in some ways like
that's his whole season that's his whole
character this season i know and i feel
like places to learn information and
just tell it to the audience and we cut
to him like once or twice and we get the
information and it's fine and i like
everybody involved but part of me is
like i would like to be here as part of
this episode with this for a little
while longer or in melatele for a little
while longer and we could maybe spread
some of this out because also too like
having the reunion of geralt and
yennefer
seems like you know it's certainly a
moment here and i'm not you know uh
bummed out by
any of how a lot of this was handled but
uh it is one of those things where even
that i was like i feel like we might
have spent more time in this
instead of it being like okay we get a
scene they kind of reunite yeah and then
oh [ __ ] now the action's breaking out we
got to move on
yeah and i'm just so at the same time
just so like
it's nice to see them back together
again yeah they do have such great
chemistry oh yeah i think uh
who plays jennifer
anya chalotra
very well done i think
that's her name
i think her performance is really good
of especially in that
scene because there's so much going on
there's so much conflict she's having to
deal with
she's desperate to regain her powers
and um
at the same time like geralt is the love
of her life she didn't she wasn't made
aware that this is the child of surprise
is the same target that she's after she
has to play this well without seeming
suspicious like i would have really
dawned on me why i'm really was really
liking her performance is when
and it's actually complementary with the
writing too
when gerald says like you've been your
heart's been beating this whole time
you've seen you've been nervous and she
just says so
i'm just like damn that's like what a
way to like lean into that
what a way to play into that without
trying to hide it because i feel like
most characters or shows they're like
i'm not nervous what are you talking
about i'm just excited or something
that's just my heart rate
but the way she just says so it's like
the way she tries to kind of turn it of
whatever the nervousness might be could
be a little bit of anticipation or
something like you interpret whatever
you want she's a comfortable like she's
just still playing it off like she's
comfortable in this position yeah
absolutely um and i thought that was
just really well done that was a really
well done performance and also um
yeah some some convenient [ __ ] but you
know what are you gonna do and the elf
child being born i uh that was nice yeah
it was nice man that's how all women
should give birth she's just gonna squat
up against the wall yeah get your
squatty potty going it's probably the
best posture for her yeah just slide out
yeah yeah it's just like a shoe how it
works man
yeah yeah i mean this episode felt like
a
more like more than a lot of the other
ones just felt like a lot of place
setting or there's a lot of plot yeah so
we cut to like a gazillion things
i mean i like the implication too that
like maybe the monsters are actually
like coming to protect siri or something
like that or to be she'll be the mother
of dragons by the end you know
well that's the fear is what is the
position that siri ultimately will hold
in here will she be a vessel for good or
evil
and
really i feel like the show can go
either way
because she's on a search for purpose
and identity that's the whole thing and
she finds more purpose and the part that
could be perceived a little bit more
malevolent then awesome that's where she
joins up next yeah whereas i i also was
like
you know i don't know if this is a
foreshadowing thing but it kind of felt
to me
that
yennefer
could perhaps still help mentor siri
along the mage path and i thought that's
maybe what they were sort of alluding to
because i don't imagine that yet that
jennifer ultimately let siri just be
surrendered uh like this like she'll go
to a certain spot
where it looks like that but i still
feel like
i don't know would it be character
assassination
uh if she were to do that uh it would it
would though
i don't know let's just see how it plays
out but it's going to mean pondering it
too much yeah i'm curious uh but uh like
they just killed off roach and it kind
of was weird to me that geralt didn't
really was kind of moved on past it
really fast he's experienced a lot of
death but for the longest time geralt
was his only friend that's his buddy he
seemed [ __ ] super concerned when he
was like yes you're before ryazkir was
even
uh before he was even informed about
yaskir being attacked and apprehended
due to trying to get information because
of geralt the second he heard
girl was like whoa yeah
is he okay yeah that's good this guy
annoys the [ __ ] out of me yeah but roach
was like siri seemed to be very
uh mournful towards the death of roach
whereas uh geralt he had his scene and
he moved on but man
could have done with like a burial
sequence or something roach was the [ __ ]
roach was yeah
that was his horse that was his best
friend yeah
roach has been which has been great for
exposition dumps
yeah yeah too
that too and hey i mean you know who are
you gonna find who's that solid in
monster fights you know probably takes a
long time bonding with your horse to get
through that [ __ ]
let's [ __ ] that more roach man pour one
out he got done dirty
yeah yeah
it was good horse acting it was good
horse acting he had some good horse
makeup
he's good yeah
okay lay down really get into character
you're not feeling good all
right was it a real horse
i think uh for some of it at least
probably
or a good maybe on the making of witcher
they have a whole
ten minutes dedicated to how they did
the horse touch just just a guy painting
the wounds
that's a mere sad
sad bessemerian wonder how people who
just watch the show
go from what if they watch nightmare of
the wolf where vesamir is like
i'm the badass
and then here is this freaking
like borderline luke skywalker
yeah it's
so
sad not exactly
when you meet up with him it definitely
lines up with his character journey and
a lot of like there's a big gap in years
yeah um at the same time man this guy is
so freaking sad and it just keeps
happening everything just keeps sucking
for and then just keeps getting worse
and just to the point where he's like
every choice i make it just keeps going
worse
and close care more and down for a while
probably man
and uh
yeah i'm going to see how the season
wraps up as a whole that's weird because
i know this has like a better critic
review yeah
than
season one
uh but right now i am kind of like there
are some things i just don't find that i
i'm not as clicked with
because i noticed it too when tris was
talking with the witchers
it just feels like sometimes we cut like
check in with the witchers just to like
be the [ __ ] at the pub
yeah
there's not much of a carrot not much
characters and and the thing is they're
juggling so much that a lot of times you
kind of have to just
be like what's the bare minimum to do
for
for these guys and the bare minimum here
the bare minimum there a lot of their
scenes have been hey i didn't mean it
come on yeah
this is how we talk
and and yeah i i it does feel maybe a
bit more like a show at the moment
whereas like season one very much felt
like this
thing that was built off of literature
partly because of the weird like the not
weird but the alternative structuring
and the alternative approach to
timelines and whatnot whereas and i've
really been enjoying season two but it
does feel a bit more like a show and a
bit more like okay we gotta cut to this
guy we we haven't seen these people yet
this episode make sure we get their time
in well this one's more accessible for
sure yeah for sure this one's much more
successful and there's a lot of things
that they do this season that i pur that
i much prefer
uh that's not to say
like if i'm doing a one-on-one
comparison i would definitely say that
there's plenty of things like emotional
wise there's a with a lot of the
characters um involves just the fact oh
cheese are just to follow
it makes a much bigger difference i
think yeah
and they feel like there's one more
thing i can't remember but what are you
going to do there's nothing
oh well we'll see what happens yeah we
still got two more to go guys what do
you think about this episode what do you
think about that action scene leave your
thoughts down below
uh very excited for the next couple
episodes
and then we'll decide which season is it
better
but right now pretty strong stuff pretty
solid work from everybody all around and
henry cavill is still killing it man
hey cass across the board a plus hey
everyone's loving everybody everyone's
great even for jill i think the the
changes that they've done with her are
very interesting because
like the way in season one you're like
bad [ __ ]
she's the bad one she's the bad one and
then
here in
in um
and nilfgaard you're like oh you're
actually
you're actually like all right you're
balancing a lot and you are seemingly
trying to do somewhat of the right thing
i also i also just love in her
performance just how much is play like
she has a lot to do in these in her face
in her just body language and
expressions because so much of her
character has to do with the political
side that she learned in aratuza and she
is now you know
building the back of her status off of
and so yeah so much
has to be kind of
not fully revealed but it's all there in
her performance yeah too like i love the
the subtle bonding moments between her
and francesca even where it's like you
can see her kind of opening up in a
different way to her like i think
they've drawn her into a very
interesting position and now with the
white flame showing up i assume next
episode you know that's gonna get nasty
no i remember dara tara
yeah yeah
he's all right he's always he's always
in the background whenever whenever we
got to nilfgaard he's like always in the
background of every frame just like
listen to him just a convenient
eavesdropper but it was just like so
ridiculously like
oh
unless he's spying
he i well he is
i mean like did he time that walking by
well that's the thing is yeah it still
is like oh wow he's in the like the
exact right place around the exact right
people to get the exact sentence
one sentence of information yeah it is a
little bit like wait a minute and that's
something too where i feel like maybe in
a differently structured episode
we might have like a dora story instead
of just like oh there he is
oh there he's outside the door when the
baby was born oh he's over there now
he's having a fight then we got this
alvin warrior to deal with mm-hmm yeah
we got uh central warrior whatever
that's called lara doran
another name i just knew off the top
yeah yeah yeah i write them all down in
my mind's eye
i i've known a lot you know laura duran
sounds like laura dern so
there you go
that's always an elven warrior in many
ways
all right guys well thanks so much for
being here let's wrap this video up you
check us on patreon appreciate all those
who do come by to watch this with us
you know it's one of the few things we
do that's not spider-man related so yeah
really for sure let's just talk about
something else
all right guys
tyler hague if ever there was a
kind-hearted warrior at the patreon page
of the real rejects it would be you if
we were yes
yep nobody else nobody else but you
carry is dismantle if we had to travel
some great distance to a far away land
to fulfill some kind of magic destiny
who would i want protecting us keeping
our spirits up it would be you tyler
hague because easily he would look
formidable you would probably scare off
a lot of the scavengers and assassins
looking to fight with us but at the same
time you're one of the most friendly
kind-hearted people around so you could
probably regale us with a song make us
feel all nice and warm out in the bitter
cold
so tyler i hope you're doing well out in
wisconsin it's probably pretty cold out
there at this moment in time so hey stay
warm hope your new year is off to a
solid start and we will chat with you
soon much love buddy stay safe
[Music]